when I was married
and I was trying to figure out if I should get a divorce or stay married
or what should I do
we have four kids
one of them is disabled
I live thousands of miles away from family
like what the fuck am I gonna do
and I was like
really searching for answers to try to like
make it work and make it stay
somebody recommended this book
why does he do that
inside the minds
angry and controlling men
and I thought it was gonna give me the answers to like
figure out how I could work with him
how can I just like
be the right partner
maybe you know
I just need to learn how to work around him
you know he's the man of the family
and I'm his wife and his supporter
and it's my job to like
kinda work around him
and then I read this book
and realized there's no fucking excuse for that kind of behaviour
and this book is fucking wild
because the dude who wrote it
Lendy Bancroft
he spent years and years and years
like 20 years or some shit
working with domestic violence criminals
helping rehabilitate them
and they all knew exactly what the fuck they're doing
you know how like
when you talk to your friends and
like other women
you hear their stories
and you're like wow
were we dating the same guy
like was they know what they're doing
they know what the fuck they're doing
they absolutely know what the fuck they're doing
and one thing I always used to say was
oh I know he doesn't mean it maliciously
like I've he just
he just had a long day
he's just really tired
you know stress is really getting to him
the fact that doesn't give you a right or a reason
to take that anger and frustration out on the people closest to you
if anything they are your comfort zone
they are the people that you can fall into at the end of the day
as a release from all that stress
they're not the person you take it out on
that's not the way a relationship should work
so if you've never read this book
I highly recommend it
if you don't can't buy the book
you can Google this
there are PDF versions available online everywhere
this author just
truly was fucking horrified at what he heard these criminals saying
and he wanted to make sure that people never fucking suffer like that again
so you should read it